[Applaus]
[Musik]
schwere Maschine
ein großer Traum
mir das erste Picknick bei -20 Grad und
viel Hürde
[Musik]
Familie Erfolg in Kanada als wiedersehen
gut 8000 Kilometer von der Schweizer Weg
ganz im Westen von Kanada
ich bin unterwegs in der Provinz British
Columbia 20
aber Temperaturen sind glaube das
Schlimmste Familie
gespannt ob es trotzdem mittlerweile so
richtig heimisch wurde sind
Mist Ziel ist Clearwater es darf mit
2500 Einwohner
[Musik]
Ihren Hund Jackson begrüßt mir sehr
schnell
[Musik]
2015 mit großer Plan
und Simone Volk ist Auswanderer abente
Maschine
[Musik]
ihres Blockhauses
einfach
unmöglich
viel Arbeitsplatz mir Hände innovative
Technik wo sie da drüber gar nicht
kennen aber unbedingt brauchen mehr ein
verträgt und wir wusstet einfach nicht
was jetzt dort dran nicht passt das ist
einfach das kann jemand verstehen
[Musik]
sie stehen
und das mal klappt's ersehnte Visum ist
da
[Musik]
warum da tragt sie erst abgelehnt und
dann doch bewilligend
[Musik]
viel Platz auf Sie
das
450 Quadratmeter groß und hat sechs
Zimmer
[Musik]
der Christian
good morning
[Musik]
das Simone falls Kanada
wenn da so bleibt
die
perfektenwanderung
Aufenthaltsbewilligung wo Simone schon
lange bearbeitet
ja hallo
Herr wähl es denn okay
das Problem ohne die
Aufenthaltsbewilligung im Land bleiben
[Musik]
denn im Sommer 2018 Erlösung
endliche stufenthalsbewilligung da und
mit der Geburt von der kleinen
[Musik]
4 Wochen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
jetzt so nicht stört du bist
was bedeutet
Freiheit wir können jetzt machen bleiben
ja und er aka hin und her kein Schwyz
wenn er will er kann immer wieder
zurückkommen sie können durch eine
musewürfe das zeigte
[Gelächter]
mega schön willkommen
vom Grundstück 130 Fußballfelder
Chef
Rudi
beim Chöre dich
unserer
richtig
und dann hätten wir mal angefangen mit
der Kühe und mittlerweile
ich verantwortlich Vorgebirge auf der
campusfahrt bisschen 80 km neu die
andere Richtung Glück haben
Wald gestanden jetzt gibt's da weiter
und dir
total unromantisch sie am Anfang mit der
Kühe bislang funktioniert hätte
Gottes 2018
[Musik]
viele investiert und dann Dezember
mit dem ja ich komme gleich und da hat
doch gesagt Holz was verkaufen genau
250.000
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
Gegend ist praktisch zum stillstanden
erholt mitbeschäftigen sie die Firma
vier Vollzeit und zwei Teilzeit
[Musik]
aber vor allem träumte davon
pilotswerten
regelmäßig ist Training zu der
luftkathete zu der Royal Canadian air
the Deads
Form kannst du mir erklären schon was
das genau ist was du machst es ist wie
man Flugzeug braucht zum Fliegen also es
geht übers Flüge er wird ziellich dass
ihr nachher Pilot sind
das militärisch wahrscheinlich
machen dass solche Sachen oder sie tun
einfach deinen Namen kommen da musst du
einfach sehr sagen
zu machen
ja wir können auch da viel lernen
wenn der nicht richtig da Abstände der
muss den Chöre wenn das da kommt
mitmachen da bringt deine so viel noch
an einem Level finde ich jetzt als du
willst nicht im Wald geholt
ich finde es langweilig und einfach das
gleiche Ding mit den paar Kontrollen
Helme und her Knopf drücken zu einem
Baum auf Verhältnis
Saures geben
immer noch ein Flugzeug fliegen ist
einfach cool aber dann kannst du in der
Luft sein mit dem vögeln
[Musik]
sind Traum vom Fliegen forderte Simone
einiges ab fürs Trainings 120 km weit in
die nächste Stadt auf kernlos
Geld ich meine das ist doch auch ja
Benzin ist im Moment
aber die Sicherheit so wenn mein
Clearwater wohnt und wird seine Kind
irgendwie
ja ermöglichen muss nichts mit dem
speziellen Sport oder eben mit der
kadette oder
ja das ist halt einfach so bisschen der
Preis wo man muss zahlen
es wird dann lange nicht für die beide
gut sieben Stunden sind unterwegs
wenn Simone
[Musik]
zum Nacht gibt es
mit Lisa seid sie rät auch die High fast
Nummern Englisch ganz anders dass ihre
e
[Gelächter]
drauf
Pilot leben
[Musik]
schon wieder Tag wach simone ist immer
die erste sie macht Kaffee und zwar
machen
grenzwertig
Brot gibt
am 60 geht's los Sport für kanadische
Verhältnis andere Holzer fangen schon
zwei in der Nacht an
Kanton Thurgau
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich kann alles montiert wo mein Koffer
hergehen hat schneemobilanz
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
um mich da angefangen habe
gesagt okay ich hatte dann Zeit du $
Scheck und jetzt kaufe und wenn der
duftbruch ist dann okay
der Technik wird dem gleichen Tag Zeit
und das immer so und wenn überhaupt
unterwegs
[Gelächter]
der erste große schlagkoffersdorf
und wenn wo sich einigermaßen fast
wieder erholt kann
auch kein Geld mehr
finanziert wird Schulz morgen
ausschließlich über spendet
ehrenamtliche Helfer unterstützen
täglich haben
man merkt den Unterschied bin
die Hände ein bisschen Buch und die
Hände Start den Tag und Sie können sich
konzentrieren
sobald der erste
[Gelächter]
im richtigen sind aktuellen Schlag 4000
Kubikmeter Holz fast zehnmal mehr als
das er früher beauftragen
[Musik]
Holzwirtschaft auf der Welt ich würde
sagen mindestens 3/4 ist Karl Schlag das
ist normal und das war mir die neue
Europas machen ist Ausnahmen
gemacht
oder wenn natürlich
der krümpel wäre und schön ist
es nicht machen
hey Kreide macht sie mobil denn ich kann
Arbeit Store entweder ist der finanziell
das spekt für die Stadt Davos lang
gehört der Macht und wenn keine Deutsch
der
ein einfache Lösung Sicht aber
tollswirtschaft segarts Kanada im Wandel
in Richtung Nachhaltigkeit
für Christian und seine Mitarbeiter ein
Vorteil dank ihrem Know-how aus der
schweizerwaldwirtschaft gibt es neue
Aufträge
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
unter anderem
20 Grad
[Musik]
Simone holt Siloballen
im Sommer
[Musik]
das Problem
aber das ist glaube vielmals Problem
Männer können mit einer die Hände ihren
Bruder
erfolgreich mit seiner Firma und den
ganzen Tag sondern
Irland bis zum Ellenbogen
oder was
Simone learning by doing
[Musik]
und wie machst du das aber alleine
ihren Platz in Kanada finden
[Musik]
in der Werkstatt vom Christian ist jeden
Freitag
[Musik]
swierobig Bier übernehmen
aber ohne Schneemobil
[Musik]
erfolgreich
originales Holz originale originale Holz
wie es gesehen
okay
ganz ganz rustikales minimalistisches
Kevin sie und jetzt haben und Dusche und
WC oder ist alles nicht so richtig egal
[Musik]
Familie
der Start Kanada ist für volksart
[Musik]
und wenn sich neue Probleme auf Türmen
müssen
[Musik]
was ihr auch alles hat überwinden darf
wenn er da vorher gewusst hättet hätte
das trotzdem gemacht
nein nie wieder ganz klar gesagt
ja wir sind gerade
dazu dass du als Sonnenhof für
Möglichkeiten und auch wieder Freizeit
hast du einfach falsch machen
weniger aber er wird Familie du bist
Lisa mehr aufwachsen wie du Johnny dem
Alter aufwachsen
denn wirst du erfolgreich
sind und genau
[Gelächter]
[Musik]